one of the crucial skills that you can
acquire nowadays is learning how to
learn and this concerns language
learning and anything else but there is
one aspect that is often neglected
within the language learning world and
it is getting ready to learn how to get
the setup correct before you start
learning anything hi my name is Luca
from Lucca labelled calm and today I'm
going to show you how I get ready to
learn any language we know that building
habits is crucial when you want to learn
anything and you want to do it for a
long time but the problem is it's
difficult to stick to your habits so one
thing that you want to keep in mind is
that when you start learning languages
and you have and you want to learn
languages every day and make sure that
you see the object that you're going to
use the language material the book
photocopies you name it just visible
when you wake up in the morning or when
the moment comes to learn because that
will remind you okay that's the time to
learn so one thing that is very easy to
do and it's a huge reminder of learning
is that I keep all my language learning
material on my desktop because that's
where I sit down and that's where I
start learning every single day when I
wake up
okay so I'm sitting down and I'm ready
to learn what is it that I do first I
have my computer on the left second I
have my language material on the right I
always make sure that I have some paper
base to material because I really like
paper based and he keeps me focused
we're going to talk about this in a
second
so what I do is that I use my computer
to listen to some audio files and in the
meanwhile I just mark words or mark the
intonation of the language on the right
so in this position it's really easy to
do two things at the same time on the
one hand literally better with my left
hand I'm just stopping the audio on and
off when they need to and with my right
hand I'm just looking at a piece of
paper marking the intonation potentially
of the text and also marking words for
vocabulary so I can do two things at the
same time with both hands
but there's one last thing there really
makes a difference and without this
nothing is useful in a way you want to
stay focused when we talk about having
refining time that's just one piece of
the framework of the entire picture the
reality is that there are two other
important factors and they're energy and
concentration in particular
concentration is so important nowadays
because we live in a world full of
distractions so the very first thing
that I do is I turn off my phone or I
put it in fly mode because your phone is
a main source of distraction and oh one
other thing don't look at your phone as
soon as you wake up it really distracts
you you want to stay focused on tasks
and just hit languages if you are an
early morning person and you learn
languages first thing in the morning so
the first point is if you want to get
into the habit of learning you better
have some visual cues just in front of
you when you wake up when you when you
start learning because that's very
important and it's an easy reminder of
oh that's the moment to learn the second
point is getting to the right position
and get the right tools for learning
remember technology can be your master
or can be your slave and if you want to
acknowledge you to be at your service
you better use technology the right way
and the third point is make sure that
you eliminate all the possible
distractions all the possible obstacles
that keep you for being focused from
staying focused for at least 30 minutes
because you have to remember that it's
not just about time it's also about your
energy and about your concentration so
there you have it if you want to know
more just click in the description box
below which will take you directly to my
blog and my website where you will be
able to read an article about this topic
and many other topics within the
language learning world and don't forget
to subscribe to this very same youtube
channel if you haven't done so and to my
blog and my website see you soon
[Music]